yeah thanks thank you so quick logistic
announcement some of you have been
asking about tower raven so
unfortunately she has to leave she has a
family emergency to deal with
so for the remaining of the workshop if
you have any questions comments and
requests please continue to come see
shibangki and me
so yeah we're very sorry that she cannot
be with us till the end of the week
so now this afternoon we're very very
pleased to have jennifer chates here
so as you know jennifer is the associate
provost and dean of school and
from
information at berkeley here
now before coming to berkeley jennifer
had a long distinguished career and
microsoft research
she was
the founder of managing the director of
three labs over there so microsoft
research in new england in new york city
and the montreal so without further ado
so let's listen to jennifer
okay and i just want to say that i'm
also that i'm associate provost of the
division of computing data science and
society
of which
school of information is a part
and just as i was pulling into the
parking lot here i got the notice that
the proposal for us to become a college
just got through the berkeley academic
senate just as i was driving over here
so we're yeah
so we're you know hopefully um
less than a year away from becoming the
first new college at berkeley in over
half a century
so which is really exciting and
of course um
you know it's computing data science and
society and so it relates to a lot of
what many of you do so who knows maybe
you'll be a part
of the college of computing data science
and society in the future
okay so
a lot of this is going to be old
material because i wanted to really
explain what a graphon is
i'll make some allusions to new work it
gets much more complex
uh uh
yeah who is here knows how
complex these things can get since she's
been working with christian borgs the
past couple of years
okay
so um
first the
i'm i'm i'm going to talk about the
motivation for doing this you know we
started work on this we when i say that
it was christian borg's
watsilovas
so it was three women and two men who
started this field
and uh
and that was around 2005 or so so it's
been a while i'll talk about graph
convergence and limit so basically how
do you take a limit of a network
then
how
once you've thought about that you get a
very rich class
of
models of random graphs that can
presumably be used to describe
real-world networks
then how do i take some measurements of
an existing big network and from that
predict the um the non-parametric
representation of it as a two-variable
function
and then uh and an application
so there are three related questions
that we asked we asked what is the
correct notion
of a limit
um
you know if you make your notion
really
weak
then every graph will converge to a
different limit if you make your notion
no sorry if
yes and if you make your notion
um
really strong then everything converges
to the same limit okay
and
you know neither of those are very
useful extreme so how did we
come up with something that we thought
was useful and the way in which we did
that
was we for dense graphs a dense graph
the number of edges scales like the
square of the number of vertices so
positive fraction of the potential edges
are occupied and for dense graphs we
came up with about six different notions
that all gave us the same limit so we
felt very good about that we said okay
we're on to something here
then how do i non-parametrically model a
real-world
network by non-parametrically
it's a it's a strange word to use in a
way because
really what it means is that you have
essentially a much
almost a bigger space of parameter so
not non
you know parametric is something like i
i have the graph g and p it's described
by one parameter p as i
do it as you know and i can go on and i
can have like a
stochastic block model where i have
you know k colors k choose two
parameters when it gets to be so big
that i can no longer describe it with a
set of parameters and i need a function
then we say it's non-parametric
um
and how do i estimate a non-parametric
representation for you know let's say
the facebook graph or something
and then give it a very small very
sparse sample of a denser graph
what how how do i predict unobserved
properties
from that
okay so um my analogy to thermodynamics
is the limit of statistical physics
which
was my training i was a mathematical
physicist by training so i think of
taking limits or
differential equations as the limit of
interacting particle systems in which i
specify every possible
interaction and we all know different
equation is much easier to to deal with
is there a meaningful way to compare
large networks by taking some kind of a
limit
the second question the modeling and
machine learning how can i take a single
snapshot of facebook or linkedin or
something today
and ask how the network will look when
it's twice as large or try to predict
something about the network
um this is a work that's a really old
work but it finally got published we
were kind of slow to to write it up so
this is probably from about
um
[Music]
2015 or so or 2016.
um so you can get an estimate of of the
graph so it's in the annals of
statistics now
and then inferring missing entries so if
i have missing entries you know you've
you know i've got a certain number of
people who've rated all possible movies
on netflix how how does netflix
get an estimate of whether you're going
to like a given movie
okay so we start with graphs
set of vertices and a set of edges edges
represented by an adjacency matrix which
just tells us whether the pairs are
connected or not
or a weighted adjacency matrix so the
the density of the the the connection
there
and
from that we get something which we're
going to call graphons which
which are going to be sigma finite
measure spaces i'll show you some
examples and a symmetric
measurable function
on those
okay
so
heuristically um
if i take the adjacency matrix of a
graph so for example if i take
this graph okay
and what i do is i represent it with an
n by n grid um
like a a
a square okay and if there is a
connection between
um a vertex
vertex two
and
uh two of the rows and and one of the
column then i put an edge there and then
i i will cut color it black in this
representation this could have been an n
by n matrix with ones and zeros if
there's a one i color it black
and then i say okay the limit is just
like take the unit square and just look
at that okay
or the random graph with p equals one
half you know i i flip a
a coin and everybody has a half chance
of connecting
and then i get something that looks like
a constant density one-half there
but what about permutations of the
vertices so i could take this
and by relabeling it would become this
well when i like take this heuristic
limit of one is it the same as the other
and the answer is yes
okay
so this was done a long time ago with
whenever you see it be it's christian
borg's
and the elves i think are all lovas
they're mostly lazy lava senior there's
also a lotsy lovas jr um
uh but anyway this is with uh lava
senior um that what you get out here so
the the analog of an isomorphism
of
the analog of a of the permutation
invariance of of the um
of the vertices in a finite graph will
turn into this function
being unique only up to measure
preserving bijections okay so the limit
of this and this are the same they're in
the same equivalence class okay
here are a few more examples if i take a
uniform attachment graph and i order it
by the
vertex vertex degrees i get this
function which is a bounded function
if i take the limit of this you know
function on on unit um square 0 1
which i can think of as just a piece of
the upper quadrant
um and i if i took preferential
attachment and ordered it by degrees i
would get this
which
is unbounded so that's interesting so
preferential attachment leads to
something unbounded
okay so the first thing we did um
which if you're coming at it from an
analysis point of view you kind of
always think this way you think i want a
metric to measure the difference between
two two graphs and so we went back to
some work by freeze and connin
um
it wasn't done in this form but it's
basically from that
if i have two
functions of two variables okay
which i can think of as like
representing
um
two two different graphs how am i gonna
compare them well what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna take the difference between
them
but
remember re-labeling shouldn't matter
okay so i take the difference between
them and then what i do is i look at the
max cut
okay the max cut of the difference
through these if i looked at just one if
w2 were zero i would literally be taking
the max cut through
the graph represented by that w1 okay
and
now because i have
this
permutation in invariance on the graphs
it turns out that what i want to do is i
want to take an emphema overall measure
preserving bijections okay so i would
have if i had finite graphs
done
a min overall permutations so i would
have said the distance between one and
two if they were the same size graphs
one and two is
i i take the
the difference between them
and i min
over all relabelings of the vertices
okay
so here it's going to be
over all
measure preserving bijections which is
just kind of a continuum reflection of
the permutation invariance
okay and then i say a sequence of graphs
converges to a graph on in this metric
if the
empirical graphs which you you the the
empirical graphs you kind of saw that in
in the picture if i take the graph and i
represent it as
an adjacency matrix
um
then uh
with
with zeros and ones okay
then
i'm going to look at so it converges to
a w
if
the the in in metric if these empirical
graphons converge to it okay so
the pictures you were seeing but always
mod this measure preserving by bijection
just like when you think about graphs
that are exchangeable you
you say mod
the the permutations of the indices
okay so that's
convergence and metric and you like a
metric because like you can bound things
and you know and you're theorists it's
nice to be able to bound things
okay but there are many other notions
that one could use like subgraph
convergence so basically i mean don't
think of the homomorphisms just
it's the same thing as saying
i am going to ask so i have this
sequence of growing graphs and i'm going
to ask that the edge density converges
and
i'm going to ask that the triangle
density converges and i'm going to ask
the four cycle density converges and the
peterson graph density converges and
i just you know so so along the sequence
i see what the what the edge density is
peterson grip all of these
finite
possible graphs
and if all of those converge
it turns out to be the same as metric
convergence which is not at all obvious
right
one is this very local thing and this
metric convergence has to do with cuts
and in fact there were as i said about
six different notions for dense graphs
graphs in which the number of edges
scale
like um
[Music]
uh
like n squared so where you know a
positive fraction of the possible edges
are are in there
and so there's a statistical physics way
of doing it i can represent
ground state energies basically
there's
looking at convergence of all the max
cuts and min by sections
there's
something to do with semi-ready
partitions if you've heard of those
there's also convergence of a large
deviation function
corresponding to having an ensemble in
which the
vertex
weights are fixed and the edge weights
are are fixed and all of these
so this is
me and christian boris with lovas and uh
shoge and western nami and then later
with david gamarnick for the for the
large deviation stuff and these are all
the same for dense graphs so dense
graphs are really really nice and you
know you've got a good notion because
everything is giving you the same notion
okay how about graphs of bounded degree
these are much more fragile
um
there's a notion of convergence called
benjamini schram convergence
which has to do with um
if i if i take a
rooted point and i look as the graph
gets bigger
i i look at the local neighborhood of
that rooted point
that if if that converges that's
benjamini sram it turns out that
subgraph convergence and benjaminish ram
convergence are the same thing on sparse
graphs of bounded degree
convergence of these free energies
is is a
strictly stronger notion
and large deviation is stronger even
than that so not
you know not getting these nice
equivalences among all the different
kinds of limits
and then the first graphs of unbounded
degree
are probably the ones we care about the
most okay when we look at things like
facebook and linkedin and
just the nature of human interaction
okay they're sparse i'm not connected to
a positive fraction of the people in
this world okay
um
as the world gets larger it's not you
know my number of connections is not
growing like n squared as as the number
of people in the world gets bigger
however
um
there's no bound uh like there are there
are people who have an arbitrary number
of connections
so it's sparse if i divide by n squared
the probability of a connection is going
to go to zero
but it's not going to be bounded okay
and so most real life networks that have
to do with human beings or sparse the
existing graph things
correspond to
a
trivial limit um
so power law graphs and a lot of these
things are sparse unbounded and so we
want to develop a theory which works for
that
and
we came up with a different notion about
three years ago called sampler four
years ago sampling convergence which i'm
not going to talk about much here but is
yet another way of doing it
that generalizes nicely from
uh dense grass to sparse grass uh
in a local sense
okay so let's just talk about
um sparse grass with unbounded so the
average degree of the graph
okay um
the the the um the
the degree of the graph is um is
diverging so if i divide by n squared
it goes to zero
but think of it maybe going to zero like
log n over n squared or something okay
so it's
so
uh think of it like the average degree
might be log n or something okay so log
n diverges right if the probability if i
if i took um
g and p type graph
and i said the probability of connection
is log n over n squared okay
or
log in over n okay
um so what i'm going to do then is this
is
this is looking down on that on that one
by one grid okay
and what happens is that
the
l1 norm of this if i if i divide
through by the density of the graph
which is going to zero
this thing explodes okay so i get these
very high
right so i'm dividing through by the
density of of the graph this is this is
getting large and i say that gn is
convergent
if they're some
function w of x and y
now not
not a bounded function anymore okay it's
it's on it's it's an r plus squared
actually such that
this is going to to zero
okay so this generalizes many of the
results for for
dense graphs
i could do something entirely different
to try to get a non-trivial limit out of
it
instead of dividing through by the
density okay which took something that
was going to zero like the density and
then made it not go to zero okay
i could instead take the underlying
metric and i could scale it by square
root of the density
so in the first case i'm staying on the
unit square
but i'm getting unbounded functions and
in the second case what i'm doing is i'm
stretching the unit square to the
positive quadrant i'm stretching the
underlying metric by square root of the
density okay
sorry square root of the norm of the
of the um
the the graph fonts and so i say that it
converges in the stretch metric
if i can find something that agrees with
it in that case
so do these notions give you know
subsequential convergence or something
like that and the answer is no because
in this case mass can disappear up to
infinity and in this case
uh oh well it can disappear up okay and
here it can disappear out
in the positive quadrant
and so solution
at the time we developed these theories
for sequences obeying some notion of
regularity which ruled out the
pathological ones where the mass was
escaping up or escaping out
and we generalized many of the results
for dent sequences
as long as the average degree
diverged
okay
so you know think of it like log or
something log in or something
so
the advantage of definition one is of
the of the one where where i divide
through by the density
is that it gives a parallel graphs
converge the degree distributions
converge
we can estimate it from a single sample
so we'll be talking about that more
later in this talk
and for bounded graphons this can also
be done in a differentially private way
so
i'll talk a lot about all these things
the advantage of the
the second one is we get very long tails
which we might have in some real world
graphs okay
the vertices that appear early get
larger degrees
so that also corresponds to the kind of
thing that we see happening
it leads to a family of growing graphs
okay in the first case when i
renormalize what i'm doing is
i'm basically
changing everything a new a new vertex
comes in
and then i have a new
number of vertices and i have a new wg
and so every time i change something
this other way can be viewed as i'm i'm
adding things on so
you're not
yes you can get more connections as time
goes on but i'm not changing the
normalization
at each time step
and also and this is work that that
we've been doing more recently um
even without this tail regularity
there's something called graphics's
which generalize graphons
and
may be appropriate in certain cases
and you can get a projective family of
those
okay so can we get a sequence which
converges in both senses you know
getting the best of both
definitions the best of both
dividing through by the density or
stretching the underlying metric by the
square root of of the density
and
theorem says that if both these things
happen then then it's dense okay then
we're just back to the old dense graph
case
what sparsity
can we achieve
you have to have
divergent
average
to to get either of these limits so
think of something growing like log n or
you know log star in i mean it doesn't
have to be growing fast it just has to
be
diverging with within the average degree
has to be diverging
okay
so now what we've seen is that we can
take graphs
and we can get these functions w which
basically describe the edge density in
various ways
now
i want to think about and they turn out
to be
non-parametric representations of our
underlying graph
now
i can start with
a feature space
and connections that come and on a
symmetric measurable function telling me
the likelihood that these latent
features may be connected to each other
and from that generate graphs which are
consistent with this so we all know or i
hope many of us know the random graph g
and p okay
i you know i say that
um any two vertices are connected to
each other with probability p i flip a p
weighted coin p might scale like one
over n or it might be a constant
whatever okay
so i can generate a whole class of
random graphs
with this model right
when i get these w's
i can actually generate whole classes of
much richer random graphs g and piece
corresponds to
constant w w of x and y equals a
constant it could be a half it could be
one over n but it doesn't depend on x
and y so i can get something much much
richer much richer class of models from
it
so generating dense random graphs first
the traditional model for dense graphs
is what's called the stochastic block
model
which is a generalization of the random
graph the random graph has one
color of particle they're all the same
color
and
i
connect them to each other
with
probability p i connect any two points
let's say i had red and blue
colored points colored vertices
i could have one probability for
connecting red to red one probability
for connecting blue to blue and one
probability for connecting red to blue
and since this is not directed yet and a
worked on some directed things since
this is not directed p blue red equals p
red blue okay
so i have
if i have k colors i have k choose two
parameters and very often
you know going back to 1983 which my god
that's a long time ago it's almost 40
years ago people would use these as kind
of a generalization of the random graph
okay and they try to fit them to things
the newer non-parametric models are
still you know they it goes back 20
years um
so but i want to think of it as i'm
given a feature space and a distribution
over that feature space and a graph on
so
i'm going to choose points
in this
feature space according to the
distribution pi so
i'm representing it as one-dimensional
but it's not one-dimensional let's think
what are the possible features
that might be relevant for you
connecting to me on facebook okay
it could be
my age it could be it could be my height
um it could be
my the field of my degree it could be my
income it could be my preferences in
music my preferences in food my
preferences and politics my right
there's like a huge space of
possible
latent features that might
explain
why
i connect
to you i don't know what all those
features are i just see
oh there are these connections right
so
i'm going to now start generating so
i've written it as one-dimensional it's
not one-dimensional you know i could
give you a hundred i could give you a
thousand
reasons why we might be connecting
so
uh you know
uh x1 is born
or enters facebook with a certain um
with a certain set of these latent
variables that are characterizing who
they are okay
x
23 i've taken a you know thousand
dimensional space and i projected it
down into one thing so the third one
that was born is the smallest in this
projection of the thousand dimensional
space onto a one dimensional six so all
these guys are born okay
and then what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
connect
x
17 to x4 with probability w
of x17x4
okay
um
i
and and then
later i'm i write and so let's say
somebody just gave you you walk in
you're a new employee of linkedin
somebody says you by the way you've you
you've just joined here's the here's the
w function of linkedin where you just
right so here it is um and now i can
denote the resulting graph that i
generate by
flipping all these w of x and y weighted
coins where x and y are my attributes
and your attributes
and i'm going to say that's an
inhomogeneous random graph represented
by
w okay
the
special case of w being a constant is
dnp
okay
or
w being you know piecewise constant um
with k choose two parameters that's the
block model k k colors
okay
so
um
boulevard did this for bounded w so
given a feature space and a probability
distribution over it and a graph on i'm
going to do exactly what i said to you
i'm going to
generate all these and then i'm going to
connect i and j with this probability
where i've now
properly scaled it by the density just
like i was doing the w
the the that first way of normalizing
something with unbounded average
average degree so i don't connect you
with
just w of x and y because what if
i mean what if x and i is a
w of x and y is unbound it's not in the
case considered by bola bosch rearden
but
what if it's unbounded okay
um
and the resulting random graph they
called an inhomogeneous random graph at
target density rho n
and i denote it by that so in other
words let's say
you know uh you you just started at
linkedin and they say hey here's our
here's our target density when we have n
people on linkedin and here's the w that
describes linkedin now start generating
realizations of them okay
so it generalizes
uh
sparse ernest rennie graphs parallel
distributions you you can get easily and
it converges in this cut metric that we
defined
if
the
um
average density goes goes to infinity
and
the the first moment of the density goes
to infinity and the density itself goes
to zero
and um this gn is exchangeable but not
projective why is it not projective
because
i keep re-normalizing at every stage by
dividing through by the relevant wn so
i'm effectively removing edges okay so i
can't think of this as something
actually building up over time
now i'm going to do something
different uh
corona and fox did this
for
a a w of x and y that was basically a
function of x times a function of y okay
and um then rory invites did it in a
more general case
so again we have a sigma finite measure
space
and we have a a graph on
and what i'm going to do and still the
the points in omega represent
you with all your underlying latent
features i don't necessarily know them i
just
but that's what it could be based on
and now what i'm going to do is i'm
going to have a poisson process with 10
with intensity tmu and i'm going to
generate
individuals with entire with their
entire set of all these latent features
in this poisson process
and then i'm going to connect i and j
with probability w of x y x j i gave you
a w you know you walked in the door
linkedin gave you their their w okay
um and then i'm going to remove isolated
vertices and get a finite graph and the
first time a vertex appears is its birth
time but we can so let me give you an
example of this
so what i've done is this is at time t1
again i have a one dimensional
representation of
this thousand dimensional latent feature
space okay
and so at time one somebody's born with
this feature which is
it's not it's a set of a thousand
features okay and at time two
this so this is somehow a
one-dimensional
representation of this
thousand
dimensional space of your possible
features
okay and then what i'm going to do is
i'm going to flip coin
w of x and y
we did coins okay
so i'm going to say somebody with you
know somebody born in this country who's
now this age living in that country who
loved physics who hated chemistry
whatever
okay the probability that they're going
to connect to somebody else
and so what happens is that at time t
one
these four vertices have been born
two got connected to four that flip came
up heads two got connected to three that
flip came up heads
three and four did not connect the flip
that they did did not connect and one
did not land up connecting with anybody
so they're not in the picture yet
okay
now
by time t2
three more points have appeared with
their sets of features okay
and
so what has happened
so when
x5 was born it tried to connect with x1
through x4 nothing happened okay
six got born it did all of its coin
flips well it connected to both four and
two but not to three
okay
and then x7 got born and oh it connected
to one
okay nobody had connected to one before
one was on facebook but nobody had
connected to it okay but now somebody's
connected with it so now one shows up by
time t t2 one shows up
okay and so these are if we use that
first definition
where we are doing the renormalization
by rho n that's what happens if we do
the second one we get these very long
tails
okay
now i'm going to tell you
about a third one which just sounds so
weird and these are graph graphics's if
you've heard of graphics's
um
they turn out to be the completion of
of sparse graphs
under some
very natural
convergence called sampling convergence
so now what i'm going to do is i'm going
to give you three things okay
i'm going to give you a w of x and y
which is going to tell me that if you
have if shibangi is feature set y and i
have feature set x this is the
probability that we're going to connect
okay
so also tell me that there's a one
variable function
um
an integrable one
which tells me
so uh you know
the star function of my set of features
um
is
a certain number that's going to be
indicating to me how many people kind of
connected to me just because of my star
power and then yeganeh has a set of
features okay
and she is going to have a certain star
power a certain number of people who
connect into her okay and then there's
this constant that represents
dust
which are
and and it's got this norm
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a poisson process just like i did
before
but i'm going to join x and x i and j
with probability w i'm going to grow a
star
and then i'm going to independently add
isolated edges
and
what this lands up looking like is
this very interesting thing that is a
little bit richer it doesn't just say
that
we connect with each other it also has
kind of i mean it's not directed but
it's kind of elements of twitter with
the star power
and
it it has some other elements
and uh you know what i'm not going to
tell you all the history of all this
stuff but it it gets complicated
um
okay
so now
what we did i'm not going to get through
all of this but that's okay
so
what we did was we had
a set of graphs we showed how by various
notions of convergence they could
converge and give you some function
which was
you know
presumably like
well what what is that function what
does that have to do with the graph you
started with that's what we're going to
be asking
if i give you that function you can
generate things that are consistent with
it just like if i gave you the constant
function p you could generate a random
graph
you know an urdish random random graph
and now i'm going to ask
given a snapshot
you know you've you've walked in you
start doing measurements on facebook can
you actually estimate their their w
okay so from a single instance can we
predict a similar graph okay the
traditional approach
for modestly sized graphs
um went back to 1983 and everything said
oh
i'm i'm assuming everything i look at is
an example of a stochastic block model
okay
so
um
i
and and so i'm i'm going to try
to approximate it by a stochastic block
model now what is the problem with that
if i have a thousand
features okay
and i have all these different values
for those features some are a continuum
of values some are a set of discrete
things
how many colors do i have
i have a really large number of colors i
mean an infinite number of colors right
because i've got like
even if they were all finite
finite set it would still be this
astronomical number of
all the configurations of these thousand
features okay
so these things don't
scale properly the best stochastic
if i say to you i wanna
i want
you to go in and measure all the
possible parameters which are growing
the number of parameters you're growing
exponentially in factorially in
one thousand okay
that's not very good it'd be it might be
better
to
ask you to estimate a function
so do a non-parametric
give give you a function rather than
give me the thousand factorial
parameters
and how badly would miss specifications
give you the
the wrong thing from those thousand
factorial parameters okay
so
the non-parametric
approach is model it is a w
estimate an approximation to that w and
then i can generate a new graph using
that w and so our task is to ex to
estimate the approximation to w from a
single sample
okay
and so the thing which i said was done
in about 2015 or 16 but we finally had
it published in annals and statistics if
w is in l2 so if it's square integrable
if the density is going to zero
and
the
average degree is diverging no matter
how slowly log star is fine for example
then we can consistently estimate this
and i'm not going to tell you how we
consistently estimated it it is
there's almost like a max min type
procedure that's that's going on
okay
okay now
i'm gonna look at
now i'm going to look at um
can i do this
differentially privately
even for things like databases we really
worry about
what gets revealed with me in a database
okay and so differential privacy says if
i'm in the database or out of the
database
you know
uh i can do a measurement that's epsilon
differentially private if
my being in the database or not being in
the database
only changes things by by epsilon
for graphs it's much much worse than
this okay because
um
the
a lot is revealed about me simply by
virtue of who i'm connected to okay so
there were
you know studies that go back now many
many years saying oh i can
you know with high probability estimate
if you're lgbtq
based on your
connections i can estimate your religion
based on your i can estimate all kinds
of things
your friends tell you something about me
okay or something about you
so
um
a randomized algorithm
is
epsilon node private
if for all graphs that differ in at most
one node
the measurement i take
the algorithm on that graph
won't change by more than plus or minus
epsilon
okay
so that's saying if you're in the graph
if you're out of the graph
an algorithm on that graph
the the randomized algorithm itself is
no private if applying it to the graph
won't
change the result by more than epsilon
there's an analogous definition for edge
privacy which a lot of people have
worked on it's easier but
it's not very useful if the edges in
there are not in there how much do
things change okay
i'm not an edge i'm a node
okay and so i don't care if you put the
edge or don't put the edge okay so if
i'm connected to bill gates or i'm not
connected to bill gates fine
you know but i really want to know
me as a node with all my connections
what does it say if i'm in or out right
and
so
previous work had been looking at edge
privacy and dense graphs and our task
was no private estimation of general
sparse graphs
and so what we showed
is that for a bounded w
where
the density was going to zero
and the
the average degree was growing at least
as fast as log n
[Music]
we could
actually show
that
i could estimate what the graph on was
in a way that did not reveal
that you know only changed up to one you
know order
one plus or minus epsilon
um
so the estimation of w is not revealing
very much about you
if
w is a is a bounded function
and then later
so this is christian borgs and adam
smith who's one of the inventors of
differential privacy and then with elias
um uh ilya sadiq
2018 we showed more than that so
the algorithm that gets used here so
what
what what gets used is that you consider
a whole
class
of possible random graphs i could
consider something as simple as just
ernest running random graph okay that's
characterized by one parameter p
um
i'm trying to estimate what the random
graph is so that's just a question of
how well can i estimate p
well what algorithm would you do i would
just
i would just you know sample randomly
and see whether it's there or not so i
take
right so i so i take a large sample of
of
of pairs of nodes and see if an edge is
there and so that's the algorithm that
i'm using that turns out to be a good
algorithm so
these um
the bounds that you use for differential
privacy are min max
in in the following sense
what i do is for any given algorithm
someone could be just as counting over
the right and and
um
so i fix a
a set of models so my set of models
could be
just the random graph it could be all
stochastic block models it could be
you know could be bigger and bigger
classes of models
for that i look at the behavior on the
worst possible graph the one that's
going to mislead me the most okay
so that's my max but then i min overall
classes of models okay
and
for the fixed algorithm my min overall
classes of of of models and that's how
you get the bound
and so if i'm
doing an estimation of w
without requiring differential privacy
i land up getting
um
certain bounds on how well i do or don't
do
in the work just with adam smith
we had showed that we could
do a differentially private estimation
but our bounds on that
in epsilon we were not as we took
epsilon to zero as we required no
privacy
the the um
statistical estimation did not do as
well
as if we had had privacy in there and
here we came up with a different way of
doing it with ilias where you got
the same min max
lower bounds and up that that they went
to the same function
as epsilon was was going to zero so
because we were asking what is the
price of requiring privacy in our
estimation
okay and now
i'll do a really fast application for
you
so i'm trying to estimate from your
rankings on
netflix or pulu or whatever
um what an entry is going to be i want
to tell you what the likelihood is that
you're going to like this film you know
and so netflix says to me oh you have a
96 agreement with this where you have a
70 agreement or whatever they're telling
me how likely i am or social network
completion or weighted social network
completion
so what these are is these are matrix
completion problems okay i've got films
i've got users
and i i want to estimate a missing entry
there okay
it what i have is from all the ratings
on netflix what i have from all the
ratings is a very sparse sample of all
possible things right
so what the oldest hoover theorem tells
me is that our exchangeable organic
matrix
can be written this this
unknown thing
can be written as
a function of the features of the rows
like
all the features about me as a person
all the possible or and the and the
columns all the possible features of a
movie
i don't know them all their latent
features right um
and uh some
iid
variable chosen uniformly at random so
here we are with that
and then what i'm going to do
is i'm going to observe each
entry independently with probability p
and that's going to get rid of this
epsilon
and
d is going to denote the maximum
dimension of the latent spaces so
there's like some
dimension of the latent spaces of
characteristics of people there's some
dimension of the latent space of movies
okay
and uh
and i'll just take the max of those two
given an observed matrix can i learn the
expectation of this to be able to
recommend a movie to you
and ideally you'd like to estimate
you know constant
degree you don't want to have to
um
have people rate any more than a
constant number of movies and is growing
okay and chatterjee
had done this um
that p would have had to sample a lot
more than that okay
so you would have had to
sample you know some much larger
fraction of the of the movies
and so the challenge of sparsity is that
there's there's no overlap there's me
and there's yeah and
i've raided panned the movie and
something else and she's rated nemo and
something else and there's no overlap
so
if i try to expand my neighborhood and
say okay well that movie there are two
people
there who have raided it and those
people have rated some other movies
and finally i get some overlap and how
far out do i have to go well this by the
birthday paradox has to be large enough
and then it turns out that if i sample
with this density
i'm i'm going to have some overlap
okay and i'm what i'm going to do is i'm
going to compare my product readings
along these paths
and the result of all that is that with
a probability that does go like one over
n
okay so i i just have to sample of order
d squared
n okay d squared's still pretty big but
at least
you know
i mean i could put a constant in front
of that and it would still be a constant
okay
and
so this is much better than the previous
one
so
we learned about graph convergence as a
way of comparing graphs okay
dense graphs boundary degree graphs and
even sparse unbounded degree graphs
where we either had to normalize through
by the density we had to stretch the
underlying space
graphons provide a way to generate much
richer random graphs than erdos-renyi or
stochastic block
you can use the inhomogeneous random
graph you can use this graph on process
or even a graphics process
and i can consistently estimate
these graphs so i can consistently
find
the w that represents some graph
okay and i can even do it differentially
private privately if w is bounded
and then you know there are many apps
and i you know there's there's going to
be a semester at simon's in the fall
which is going to involve graphons and
networks and you know in the subsequent
years since we started developing this
it's just been applied in hundreds of
different circumstances so maybe now
when you hear graph on you'll have a
little bit of an idea of what it is
thank you
so basically when you have like a set of
observations of graphs or just a huge
graph and you want to be build w you're
gonna approximate w basically right yes
so
in huge graph there's probably
a way to sample the graph to evaluate w
in a better way right so what would be
the strategy to do that well okay so the
proofs which are very very very general
it takes way too long okay you're
basically approximating it by
stochastic block models of various sizes
permuting over things so
um
the proofs which cover all the worst
case scenarios okay are not very
are not very efficient but you can say
i'm going to look over a class like a
stochastic block model and then take the
limit of that
okay that is that is one way of
of doing it but you need some hacks
otherwise
it will take forever
okay
if you have some prior information about
the distribution of the graph
is it better to use this distribution to
sample the after value
better yeah
um yeah thank you for the talk uh i'm
just wondering what are some like one or
two open questions in this area which
so you know in even in the theoretical
area there's a lot actually so we did
all the estimation stuff for the
inhomogeneous random graphs
but the ones that are the process which
are people in the statistics community
are very excited about we haven't done
any of the estimation theorems for
for that so it's a really um
i i think it's a really important
question to prove that you can
estimate things
properly
using this
this other way of doing it with that
that comes about from this graph on
process okay so so that's what we we
have come up recently with something
which we call sampling convergence
um where we were able to show that we
can do some things where sampling
convergence over time you have a poisson
process that tells you how to sample
okay so but do the estimation theorems
based on that for example
if you have
if you have an estimation of w could you
use w to generate like a generative
model oh yeah okay that's the whole
point of it if you can estimate w
then
you know then you can have then then oh
i want to i i want to learn something
about this network i can generate things
which are distributionally
similar to the graph i've i've gotten i
can try all kinds of things on them so
you could build like a
a synthetic data set yes
sampling
facebook and generating
new graphs that doesn't really exist but
they mimic the distribution
yes absolutely i mean that's one of the
big points of this why do you want this
w
so that
you can generate things which are
distributionally the same and that works
that people did on using this method to
generate this data set is it like common
yes i mean in the last 10 years at some
so i first we first started proving
theorems about it
and i thought you know was motivated by
trying to do things on web spam and i
thought what's the limit and i asked
lots you love us what's your notion of
women and they didn't have any and it's
like oh my god somebody has to develop
this we went off into what i called math
land
and then i don't know what it was maybe
2012
you know i went um
um i went to narips and there were all
these people doing graphon estimation
you know without proofs proving that any
of it could work but yeah people just
grabbed onto it because of course you
don't want to do
a parametric estimation
where the number of parameters you need
is growing factorial in the potential
size of the latent space right i mean
that's just that's a nightmare right
better to get a function and assume some
properties some smoothness properties or
something about it
so i have a quick question so
essentially you were
creating a recommendation system right
for movies and stuff so before
people or you guys created graphene
stuff what was the main algorithm that
people used for a recommendation system
and in your implementation of yoga and
you see
sort of difference in performance
so
it's it's interesting because um
[Music]
deborah vrat shaw
uh who is working with us and
christina you who is now chris or
christina lee who is now christina lee
you
um
was doing
help company on on recommendations
and so some of this stuff was performing
very well okay
um
so you know uh
people tried to do more parametric
kinds of things
before
which um
made things not scale very well at all
okay so you saw
these coming into the wrong place
the the dimension of the latent space
coming into the wrong place
whether
drawing a similar network on twitter
like that algorithm whether it stands on
that is their work on the kind of more
space to average
well so some of these theorems are
exactly looking at i mean we can't prove
the theorem without
looking at worst case okay
i mean that's how we establish that
something is possible is basically we
have to consider worst case
but um
but i think uh robustness results would
be would be really nice okay and not the
average hardness results will be
so more questions we're going to take
offline so we take a short break
back at 3 30 and hope to see everyone
there and i'll write the names of
whoever